[Musique]
bonjour ça va bien pas content vous rend
contenu parce que vous avez un nouveau
spectacle créatures oui toujours dans
l'objectif de démocratiser la drague la
drague ça peut être tout et n'importe
quoi qu'est ce que vous avez voulu faire
est-ce que je les fasse surtout sortir
la drague des bars donc d'un milieu
assez hermétique dans les grandes villes
fermées pour les adultes seulement
lorsque j'avais envie cette affaire la
rencontre la famille donc c'est vraiment
de 6,7 à 177 en partie des possibles
la drague ça va être très physique alors
est-ce que rita boga centrale et comment
elle développe son talent
l'entraînement c'est toujours défi en
fait le chantre et de m'installer en gym
à la maison confidences s'avère jeu
saura sauvage des sables accès s'est
vraiment rendu un entraînement ce
spectacle et boissy c'est un dopant dans
le spectacle je sue et c'est très
physique je suis seul sur scène mais
changement que sim se font en bas de 2
après t'avoir de une minute 40 j'ai mon
conjoint qui sur la scène avec moi qui
co produit le spectacle aussi qui qui
aimons à billère pendant le spectacle
est aussi régisseur donc on s'est
vraiment comme une histoire de famille
ce spectacle et c'est très physique rita
boga de faire une bonne dose de courage
en 2007 pour jean-françois lièvremont
pour créer tabaga envers et contre tous
je veux savoir ce qui s'est passé dans
votre tête à l'époque mais pour moi 2007
quand je les teste pour la fête d'une
amie directes telles histoires d'un soir
et finalement je me suis fait prendre au
jeu je tombais d'âge et la piqûre tout
de suite après ça a été quand j'ai pris
ça plus au sérieux ça a été comme un
deuxième commune ya des familles de la
danse à ma famille mes amis un homme à
nantes pour annoncer que vous êtes
dragway et salue un effet plus grand que
mon coming out comme personne courir
parce que les gens avaient les mêmes
stéréotypes et préjugés que j'avais sur
ce métier de 7 à 10 c c'est ce serait
dans les bars allemandes ont créé des
personnes qui consomment avec travail
pas de jaux sada toute la journée
j'avais beaucoup d'appréhension et
préjugés et ma femme et mes amis aussi
donc fallu l'expliquer et longtemps gelé
cacher que je faisais de la drac j'ai
fait des études jusqu'à la maîtrise je
le disais pas mes collègues d'études les
résoudre au monde une maîtrise en
gestion développement du tourisme qui
j'ai décidé de
de le dire en fait quand il ya eu il de
jour et de nuit
documentaire
si art tv parce que l'on voyait
carrément un lecteur et en jean françois
et depuis ce temps je vois quelque chose
de connecter je dise plus besoin de ses
parts et neerman l'elysée
vous êtes dévoilé dans canada doit grèce
va aussi les missions avec bruxelles
abouti rita bagua lorsqu'elle retourne à
la maison loin de la scène elle doit
vivre avec jean-françois il ya vraiment
son créateur depuis 2007 comment ça se
passe tous en moi j'aime beaucoup le
fait d'avoir une espèce de d'armure qui
hérita pour ouvrir des portes et en fait
je suis défoncé les portes puisque les
ouvrir ou briser certains plats sont
ouverts j'aime beaucoup le l'espèce de
pouvoir qui vient avec mon personnage de
rita est rendu à la maison j'ai apprécié
la tranquillité et je suis pas griffer
des bains de foule ou qui aiment se
faire reconnaître ça me gêne souvent
plus qu'autre chose donc est à la maison
tranquille je fais mon petit jardinage
j'écoute mes programmes ce matin hier
jusqu'à même assez cavalière quand je
peux l'être mais en même temps j'ai
toujours beaucoup de projets en même
temps
voici longtemps vous dit que la drague
c'était un accotement un passe temps de
vie un autre employeur la supplique aux
jeunes c'est à temps plein c'est ce
n'est plus qu effectivement depuis
décembre landry en fait j'ai déjà
longtemps fait deux emplois temps plein
chez d'un écran la programmation pour le
festival fierté montréal de jour et le
soir et parfois même deux jours j'étais
aussi lutins donc j'ai été longtemps
dans un espèce de suite de combinaisons
d'horaires 80 heures semaine pour
beaucoup du sommet je réponds que j'ai
plus de ça mais maintenant mais j'ai
beaucoup plus d'opportunités comme
ritter je dis toujours aux gens qui
hésitent à se lancer dans leurs pensions
qu'on a juste 100 % d'énergie dans la
vie et 100% de tendre quand on pense en
pourcentage de vos sondages qu'on
attribue à un projet mais c'est le
pourcentage de rothau qu'on aura part à
ce projet la rue tabaga merci beaucoup
pour cette entrevue est bon tournée
merci
c'est comme ça
[Musique]